hi I'm Ryan I'm gonna be watching the
trailer for welcome to yesterday
everybody's been telling me to watch
this have no idea what this movie is
about but I'm looking forward to
watching this trailer all right here we
go time to welcome yesterday
hello yesterday how are you dad's old
camera working again okay that's my
seventh birthday would you see that what
I just saw something weird you guys you
gotta feed it there's this footage of me
at my seventh birthday we're all your
something yeah just watch this right
there look in the mirror that's me
that is my t-shirt that was my backpack
this is definitely me it doesn't make
sense she's hot it's in my dad's old
workshop it's like a clicking or
something support machine
there we go project Almanac that's
something my dad was working on temporal
relocation prototype we see means time
travel what
we should try to build it you can't
build a time machine didn't you see the
tape at your seventh birthday I mean I
think we already did build it so there's
some smart kids you know how to build a
time machine Michael Bay you know it's
good like a second chance machine
I just failed My Chem report was the
classification of silicon silicon are
you kidding and I don't want to repeat
12th grade everything I would do none of
this happened before whatever we did I
had some crazy ripple effects we just
equation never time-travel ever jumped
in the first place can I do that oh I'm
gonna go back and fix everything
things are smiling out of control did
you ever think that it was dangerous
although I know this hasn't already
happened
keep thinking I can go back and I can
fix it myself I can time travel he never
worked out to see how to make it go back
even further it could kill you too I can
see why people wanted me to watch that
and honestly it looks a little bit like
I you know every time traveling movie
does that you know like oh time
traveling is kind of cool but then
everything gets [ __ ] up you know that
butterfly effecting yeah but if I had a
time machine I would probably time
travel back in time and [ __ ] Katharine
Hepburn because who do you know today
that has actually had sex with Katharine
Hepburn's all dead now